and you're watching book TV on c-span -
this is live coverage of the Miami Book
Fair that was scientist James Glick
talking about his most recent book on
time travel a couple more hours left in
our live coverage this afternoon we've
got a couple call-in programs we've got
a couple more author presentations so go
to book TV Norg you can get the full
schedule there while joining us here on
our book TV set is author Steven Johnson
before we get into your most recent book
would you think about you were listening
pretty intently to what James Glick had
to say you know James Glick is one of my
favorite authors of all time he really
his book from a million years ago chaos
which I read when I was in college was
the first kind of popular science book
that I that I read in my entire life
that really started me thinking that I
could potentially be a science writer
because I had not been interested in
science at all so he's - Michael so if
he were still talking I would actually
just say we should go back and listen
more - here you have to listen to me now
well your most recent book is called
Wonderland right what what were you
trying to explore in this book
well Wonderland is a history of things
that human beings have done for the fun
of it for the delight in it so for for
the feeling of play or amusement and it
came out of the book how we got to now
and the in the PBS series said I did a
couple years ago which was really a
history of innovation and a history of
things in the modern world that we take
for granted and trying to tell the
500-year for a thousand year history
behind all these things and so that was
a really great format to work in I love
that kind of historical work there were
a lot of just interesting stories and
that and you could you could write that
book up thousand times over because
there's so many things that that you
could write it about but I wanted with
this book to have an actual argument
about history kind of a theory of how
change happens in society and the
argument of Wonderland is that that
history of things that we do for fun
things we do for delight
actually ends up triggering much more
serious than momentous changes in
science and in technology or in politics
so things that start out at kind of
frivolous amusements end up changing the
world a much more significant ways where
did the concept of this come from well I
you know it's what these books where
I've been kind of researching it for 20
years in some ways it opens up with a
chapter after the introduction about the
history of fashion and shopping and I
had heard when I was in grad school more
than you know 20 years ago well more
than 20 years ago I'd study the 19th
century metropolitan novel and you know
so I was reading Dickens and Balzac and
Zola and there's an incredible story
about the first department stores when
the first department stores come to
Paris the BAL Marche really the first
great you know immense spectacular
shopping Wonderland really this
extraordinary thing happens where all of
these well-to-do women who don't need to
do this for economic reasons whatsoever
come into the store and they start
stealing from the store this is a true
story there's this there's this wave of
kleptomania among the kind of wealthy
women of Paris in the ball marche and
these other new grand department stores
and no one can figure it out because
they don't they don't they could pay for
the goods but for some reason the store
environment is causing them to the steal
and so this provokes is huge kind of
moral panic and discussion about it and
it becomes known as the department store
disease and eventually a whole theory of
the mind develops out of studying these
women which is to say oh wait it appears
that new configurations of modern life
you know new spaces new commercial
environments is actually messing with
people's brains you know and it's a
beginning of the line of kind of way of
talking about the brain that we have
today when we think about how our video
games affecting the brain or house
television if I be in the brain or what
so on so I you know I had stories like
that that I've been accumulating for the
last 20 years and and so once I started
to research I could kind of put it all
together well Stephen Johnson you call
this our endless quest for delight yeah
I mean if you think about what you
learned
when you were in school about the forces
that drive history right youyou would
think okay there's a quest for power
there's kind of tribalism or nationalism
they're kind of religious beliefs
there's you know survival money those
are the big forces that drive history
but there's this other side of being
human which is we're amused by things we
like to play we like to have fun we like
to be surprised and delighted by new
experiences and so that's it that's I
think you're kind of a lovely side of
our history and it turns out to be
filled with all these crazy stories that
are that are also fun to read now if you
have read Stephen Johnson in the past
you know what kind of books he writes
his most recent just out it's called
Wonderland how plain made the modern
world now we're going to put up the
phone numbers so you can call in and
participate in the callin program today
with Stephen Johnson
2:02 is area code seven four eight 8200
if you live in the East and Central time
zones 202 seven four eight eight two
zero one for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zones go ahead
and dial in and we'll get to your calls
very quickly Stephen Johnson is a
best-selling author he referenced his
book how we got to now six innovations
that made the modern world there's also
future perfect the ghost map everything
bad is good for you as well now in
Wonderland you talk about how our
so-called endless quest for delight has
changed or led to exploration and stock
markets and computers and
probability-based insurance policies
yeah I play in that war if anyone well I
mean actually there are two ways in
which it leads to the modern insurance
business the first is there was a crazy
figure from about 500 years ago this
Italian mathematician and chronic
gambler named Cardno
who had basically spent his whole life
doing dice games and gambling but it was
kind of a math genius on the side and
near the end of his life he just he
figured out he kind of figured out a way
to understand mathematically the
likelihood of various
games of chance outcomes like in a game
of dice like what's the likelihood
you're going to roll three sixes in a
row what said you're going to roll a 12
versus a seven and no one had actually
done the math on this they'd understood
that if you're rolling two dice twelve
would be less likely than a seven but no
one has quite figured out how to explain
it and so he wrote this book that was
both kind of a cheat sheet for how to
win it dice and also very advanced math
it became the basis for probability
theory and that theory then got refined
and and modified over the years and that
became then the basis of a whole host of
elements of the modern world the
insurance business without probability
theory can't do anything it's not a
business about probability math but the
other side of it that connects to the
book seems is that the first modern
insurance firm which was Lloyd's of
London took took place in a coffeehouse
and I have a whole other chapter about
coffeehouse culture and tavern culture
and these spaces designed to you know
for leisure and for hanging out and just
sitting around drinking coffee or
drinking beer and so Lloyd's of London
was originally a coffeehouse called
Lloyd's coffeehouse and so both dice
games and coffee houses came together to
form the modern insurance business
public spaces how did we get to public
spaces well you know in a way you know
that the tavern is kind of the beginning
of this so the world is now filled with
just countless you just look around you
and think how many spaces are engineered
specifically for you to have fun in some
fashion all around the world right from
movie theaters to parks to you know bars
and coffee houses and shopping malls I
mean the world is filled with these
things most of which didn't exist 300
years ago even much less a thousand
years ago and one of the first spaces to
do that was the the bar the tavern right
that there was a space it wasn't work it
wasn't home it wasn't just nature it was
a space where you could go in it was
kind of semi-private semi public and it
was designed for you to pass a few hours
have a good time and that alone is kind
of nice it's nice to know where these
things came from but bars and taverns
have played a really momentous role in
the history of politics all right in the
history of this country
you cannot tell the history of the
American Revolution without tolerance
right there at every step of the way
they were the kind of key information
node in the network of kind of anti anti
English sentiment during that period now
it's possible that we would have had an
American Revolution had bars and taverns
not been invented but it would they
would have required a different paths I
mean it would have required a different
set of meeting places for it to happen
so it's a big it's a big part of our
history what do we do with the
information that you've shared with us
in Wonderland well I think it's a
reminder of how creative the the playful
state of mind is right when we're when
we're being amused when we're being
delighted by something it seems to lead
to more and more innovation people just
get into that sate and they're like
that's fun that's interesting what if we
added this or change this and there's
something about that state that I think
is really powerful there is as we kind
of alluded to with the dice game story
there's a whole chapter about the
history of games and think about games
in the context of Education I mean I
think this is a really interesting field
when you watch kids playing games
whether they're video games or board
games or educational games they
concentrate the mind right I mean you
know I'll I play these these kind of
simulation games with my kids who played
them when they were seven or eight and
they will be building an entire like
geopolitical empire in the game and
learning about legal systems and
learning about different historical
periods of learning about taxation rates
when they're seven and they're not of
not saying they're particularly gifted
it's a nature of the game that pulls
identified sat them down and tried to
teach them about you know tax reform and
industrial development when they're
seven they would never pay attention but
the game structure pulls you in and
makes you makes you want to learn in
spite of yourself well let's hear from
our callers Steven Johnson let's begin
with Wayne and San Diego Wayne you're on
book TV with author Steven Johnson go
ahead yes I want to rest a Johnson has
read Johan Huizinga is a homo
was a man a player and translate if he
has read the only translation I've been
able to find what he thinks about the
irony of what the author insists the
preposition should be in our culture so
clearly please hold yeah it's a
fascinating book homo Luden's it was
written right at the beginning of world
war two and in fact we're going to
eventually died in world war two so you
have this kind of extraordinary saying
of this kind of anthropologist
sociologist writing this epic book about
the history and the centrality of play
to the human species as the Nazis are
marching across Europe it's kind of
tragedy in the middle of a really
powerful book so I quoted actually at
the end of the at the beginning of the
final chapter I think is approach is the
basic idea that play is central to human
culture is obviously we share that he
approaches a little bit more abstract a
little bit more kind of philosophical
whereas if you get a chance to see
Wonderland it's filled with very kind of
specific examples of how this instinct
or appetite for play actually came to
pass and all the kind of crazy stories
of people trying to amuse themselves in
ever more inventive ways so that the
approaches of the two books
philosophically are very much aligned in
terms of in practice are a little
different
let's hear from David and Rochester New
York hi David you're on the air thank
you how you doing yes I'm not just in
New York and I wonder if you know here
in Rochester we have the strong Museum
of play and it's a it's a history of all
play items throughout history all
different kinds of things and if book TV
ever comes to Rochester New York you can
come to visit so I wondered if you ever
heard of it I had heard of it I have not
been though I need to make a pilgrimage
there I think look I'm on book tour I
need to do an event there hey it's at ok
and it's really I mean this is the thing
what
what you know how do we how do we think
about the role of these objects of
physical objects of play where do they
go in the way that we think about
history right do we think of them as
just kind of something at the margins
that the real history happens on the
battlefield or it happens in Parliament
or do we recognize that that play space
and these objects that we've made have
been you know for thousands of years a
really important part of the kind of the
march of progress and the advance of
civilization I think it's it's a ladder
so it's good that we have some museums
out there celebrating this everyone
should go to Rochester New York Stephen
Johnson was chess a technological
innovation was kind of a conceptual
innovation that then led to
technological innovations because chess
was central to the early days of
computing I mean if you look back the
first essays written about the you know
in a rigorous way about the idea of
artificial intelligence in Alan Turing's
essays we're all kind of anchored in
this question of could you teach a
computer to play chess and he was saying
you can teach it it might be done but
yeah it would be possible yeah in a way
he was a little bit too pessimistic
about because now computers are you know
better than humans applying chess but
that took a long time and and so I mean
it's a it's a great example of the power
of play here so all along in the history
of artificial intelligence gains have
been the way in which we both measure
and train these these new machines right
so it started initially started with
checkers right it was a simpler game
because there's no way to get the
computer to play chess and then it
turned out they got pretty good at
checkers and then we brought in chess
and backgammon and gogo is the next big
hurdle but look at Watson the IBM
supercomputer which is probably arguably
one of the most intelligent kind of
forms of artificial computation out
there and how did they train Watson they
trained it by having it play jeopardy
and eventually win at jeopardy so
they're like we need to figure out a way
to train this machine I think a game
show would be the perfect way to do it
so the connection between gaming and
and digital technology is a very rich
one now we were looking at iPhones a
little bit earlier don't you Siri I do a
little bit yeah just a little bit I was
just talking to somebody the other day
but someone should should remake 2001 a
Space Odyssey with Siri as how and so
it's like open the pod bay doors very
and series like I'm sorry Dave I didn't
understand what you said here are three
sites where you got that yeah look at
the found this on the web how advanced
is Siri and she she is kind of a play
toy in a sense
yeah we're just we're just at the
beginning of this so so this actually
can in one of the there's a chapter in
the book on illusion and about how much
time we've spent tricking our eyes into
perceiving things that aren't there
starting with perspective and painting
going through you know these kind of
magic lantern shows and then the cinema
and all this comes up on one of the
arguments that I made in that chapter is
there is something about just as with an
optical illusion
you can't you you know that it's a cutey
image but you still see that 3d square
and you can't tell your brain otherwise
your brain just has to make that mistake
because that's just the way our brains
are wired something similar happens with
moving pictures and sound once you get
to more than twelve frames per second
and a close-up of some of a human being
talking with audio you just feel like
you know that person right you feel like
you've built in some kind of emotional
connection to that person that's why we
have celebrity culture in an age of TV
and movies and stuff like that and I
think what we are going to experience
pretty soon is a similar kind of
emotional illusion where we have these
virtual systems like Siri only the
assistants actually know us a little bit
they can engage in real conversation
they change over time adapting to what
we say and so after you've been with
this assistant for a year they will have
a unique personality custom tailored to
you and and I guarantee you people will
develop very intense emotional
connections to these devices this is
like the movie her that spike Jones's
movie
and it may start with voice because
voice is a lot easier to do than facial
expressions and so we may have these
very complicated in the next five years
maybe relationships with completely
artificial characters and live in our
devices
kimberlly's in Baldwin New York hi
Kimberly you're on with author Steven
Johnson hi yes I was calling to see if
perhaps his book touches at all on the
philosophy of aesthetic realism and the
work of Eli Segal because just based on
your description of your work which I
look forward to reading there more so
focused with art rather than play but
you seem to have some similar similar
things going on no you know it doesn't
it was really interesting question
actually in the book of how I was going
to handle art right because there there
is a chapter on music and there is a
chapter on illusions which gets into
cinema and animation and the history of
that but other than that I tried to
steer away from art that was
particularly representational so for
instance the the literary novel which
I've spent a lot of time reading because
I went to grad school in English
literature and it's a great passion of
mine and and representational painting
where you have work that is trying to in
a sense speak to our higher faculties in
a way that is trying to address big
sweeping questions about what it means
to be human or the nature of reality and
so on because those didn't seem playful
enough but I was trying to like I think
we already accept the idea that serious
are serious narratives fiction is an
important part of our cultural history
and so I didn't feel the need to make
the case for that since others have
already made it more eloquently than I
could what I was trying to do was to
make a case for kind of the lower forms
and I included music in there because
there is this mystery about music which
is we have no idea what it's good for
right that if you think about how much
music moves us and Alex
we feel for music and yet it seems to
have no functional value at all it's
unclear why these kind of waveforms
floating in the air through our ears
should produce these very strong
feelings and so that was an opening that
allowed me to write about music in this
in this book but I didn't I didn't cover
a aesthetic realism and things like that
in this in this one but maybe in another
one
Albert's in Houston Texas hi Albert go
ahead Albert - with us I think we lost
Albert so let's move on to Ahmad in
Royal Oak Michigan Ahmad you're on with
author Steven Johnson hi hi how are you
guys
we're good please go ahead with your
question or comment okay my question is
on technology and I just want to know is
like how can we make social media better
for the next generation and just making
it safer for like children and kids you
know especially nowadays well Martha you
know we hear from if before we hear from
Steven Johnson what would you like to
see changed I would like to see like
this social media just working faster
you know for the use and like blacking
out like uh some of the negative ads and
things yeah what kind of technology do
you use I use my iPad and my cell phone
thank you sir
great well it's you know it's a really
important question and I've written
about this actually less in Wonderland
but in some of the other books like
future perfect and even going back to a
book emergence that I wrote a long time
ago when you move to social media you
basically move from a system where you
have a bunch of gatekeepers
editors
you know folks who are controlling the
flow of information who are deciding
what's true and what's not what's
appropriate and what's not what's
newsworthy and what's not and we shift
to this distributed system where the
whole network is how everybody on the
network is potentially generating news
or sharing ideas or creating an
editorial filter deciding that this is
relevant or not and I think this has
worked pretty well for a while but I
think we have seen you know in the last
decade in the last few weeks so some
significant cracks being in beginning to
appear and so I think because my concern
really right now is particularly with
something like Facebook which is the
Facebook is the size of an entire medium
now I mean it's it's you know almost as
big as the web itself right
and yet that medium which has a huge
impact over what we read what we consume
what we feel about politics what we feel
about what our children experience we
don't really have any control over how
that medium works the way we do
technically over the web the web is an
open platform that can people can modify
and expand on and push in different
directions Facebook is a platform that's
owned by private company and yet it's
the size of the Internet or the size of
the web in many ways and so when we want
to change something we want to make say
for instance something like Facebook
less vulnerable to fake news for
instance is the topics been on the
everybody's tips of everybody's tongues
the last week or two we have to kind of
go and ask Facebook to change it we it's
not an open standard that we could
change and so that's that's gonna be
something we're gonna have to wrestle
with over the next few years we've got a
president-elect - likes his Twitter
account it is fast anybody I've been a
longtime user of Twitter and I think
there is an argument that that without
Twitter he wouldn't have want I don't
think he might not have been able to he
I think he might not have won the the
Republican race because it just gave him
this kind of mouthpiece for zero dollars
basically so why does he need a filter
ie the media to filter it today I think
he in many ways decided he doesn't I'm
and I think you
and and what what happens that Twitter
account in the White House is going to
be fascinating as you know if there's
the various points of it in the race
where it apparently is people like took
his phone away from him so he couldn't
tweet anymore and but they seem to have
given it back to him and so apparently
he's just going to keep tweeting from
The Oval Office which is and he puts us
in a whole new world and mr. Trump will
get the POTUS account
yeah and mrs. Trump will get the FLOTUS
account those are transfer over connect
next call for Steven John's as the
founders intended
do you think they had any idea though
well they were very interested in in
communication I mean one of the things I
wrote about an invention of air which we
talked about many years ago in the Adams
Jefferson Adams Jefferson letters that
are the famous correspondence between
those two when they and they had fallen
out as most people probably know they
hadn't spoken too many years and then at
the end of their lives they start this
epic correspondence and the way they
begin the conversation for the first few
letters is basically kind of nerding out
about how fast their letters are getting
to each other which was the state of the
art in the communication infrastructure
at the time and so they're like oh your
letter only got here in in six days from
Monticello that was very impressive you
have very high bandwidth can imagine of
emphasis so they wouldn't have they
would have been shocked but then they
would have quickly figured it out
David's in Beloit Wisconsin and David
you're on with Steven Johnson his newest
book is called Wonderland oh yes good
afternoon my grandfather started a toy
company in 1920 and he had a philosophy
that he wrote a lot about which was
bringing reality into the land of
make-believe and if he was alive I never
knew him I would have argued that we
need to keep play and reality separate
until he believed that by giving
children actual miniature real things
his workers in the Smithsonian he went
to a lot of mobile to make his toys so
real that he said children
sort of playing with a fantasy object
would now be playing with a real object
and therefore become more realistic and
go on to lead corporations and do
practical things and I would have argued
with him that play should be open-ended
and not directed at making children more
pragmatic
I think play should be open-ended David
I think we got the point let's hear from
massager so that's a great really
interesting family history you know the
blurring of the lines between reality
and and kind of play spaces is a really
interesting one and there and there
they're just in the history of games
there is a big kind of divide between
games that are very kind of strictly
limited and the rules are really defined
I mean I remember when my kids were
young and I would play Candyland with
them and I would play Candyland and
finally I was like you know what's crazy
about this game there is no choice in
this game you literally cannot make a
decision you just pick a card and you
have to move your piece no matter what
it says and so that is the ultimate kind
of constrained game I was like this is
ruining the kids of America's brains I
they have no free will in this game and
then you go to the other extreme and you
have games like you know Dungeons &
Dragons or some like that where you're
inventing a whole world and it's all
about changing the rules and going in
and I think they're developmentally
there are kind of different games at
different times but but the other
question that you raised is the blurring
of the boundaries between the real world
and the and the play world and that is
something that we are going to see more
and more of and we saw the first great
kind of explosion of it this summer with
Pokemon go right here you have a game
that is on some level very frivolous and
you know not that important in any
functional way but it brought all these
people out into the world exploring you
know looking for these imaginary
Japanese creatures my kids were just
begging to go for a walk for the first
time in their lives they wanted to go
outside because their screen was going
to capture things outside but they were
still going for walking getting extra
and and this is this is one of the big
arguments of Wonderland which is that
when we look at what people do for fun
when we look at people playing it's
often a predictor a predictor of more
serious changes coming to society so the
line of the book like wherever you'll
find the future wherever people are
having the most fun right and I think
we're going to look back and in ten
years or so when we're all walking
around with kind of augmented reality
goggles when virtual information is
being superimposed over the real world
we'll say oh this started with Pokemon
go it started with kids running around
chasing imaginary kind of Japanese
creatures but now we do it at part of
ordinary life and kind of the straight
life but it began in a game virtual
reality is kind of taken off this year
ahead a little bit yeah yeah a couple of
major devices have come out and I wrote
a piece for that for The Times Magazine
actually adapting some of the material
in the illusion chapter thinking that if
we went back and looked at these early
19th century illusion shows like the
there was this kind of haunted house
show called the phantasmagoria and then
there was a 360 degree painting called
the panorama and all hundreds of other
different kinds of shows I think those
shows are a preview of kind of coming
attractions they're going to come to us
in virtual reality and what those shows
had that's very interesting is they
weren't about stories and they weren't
really about characters you didn't go to
them the way you would go to the movie
to find out follow a plot or to feel
empathy for a character they were about
being thrown into a space and immersing
yourself in kind of a sensory overload
of that space and being frightened or
amazed or feeling you were transported
somewhere but they weren't narrative and
I think when people look at virtual
reality they're trying to figure out oh
how do we translate video games to this
new form or how do we translate movies
to this new form and I think actually
going back and looking as I tried to do
in Wonderland at these earlier forms of
amusement might be instructive but I
think the example is that I used in the
pieces if James Cameron were making
Titanic
for VR the whole storyline
of the rogue
handsome dashing stow away with the
well-to-do lady you wouldn't want any
that would just be a waste home you just
want to be on the ship you know and you
just want to run around and like jump
off the edge and try and survive or try
not to you wouldn't care so much about
the characters it would be about the
environment and I think that's what
we're going to learn with with VR but
again looking back at these older forms
of play I think it's very illustrative
bills and Minneapolis go ahead bill
we're listening hi I have a background
in mathematics and I have also taught
introductory mathematics to adults and
I've become convinced first of all that
the the mathematical talent requires in
part a spirit of play and playing with
conceptual worlds and manipulating them
and children have oftentimes exhibited
when they haven't been poisoned by the
adults a willingness to play with
mathematical ideas when they're first
introduced and so they play with numbers
and what can you do with numbers and I'd
be interested in your comments on the
this relationship between mathematics
and play and how to teach you than the
rest of that thank you thank you sir
yeah that's a great observation you know
there's a story in the book about really
the first wearable computer you know
kind of a computer small enough that you
could put it conceal it in your body was
developed by two guys one of whom was
Claude Shannon who was a kind of genius
mathematician and early advocate for
computers was involved in a lot of
fields and they built this device to win
it roulette to beat the house at
Roulette in Vegas and they figured out
this kind of crazy way of calculating
when the ball is dropped exactly how
long it took before it kind of started
to settle and you could make predictions
based on that if you had an accurate
sensor and a little computer on you and
they and they successfully did it
actually and it was so far from being
even conceivable because this is in the
late 50s when most computers were the
size of like a room much less uniform
you could fit in your pocket and so it
wasn't the kids of law like it wasn't
against the rules of the house because
nobody'd even imagined there could be a
computer right so they they did this but
Shannon
and in it and I talked about this in the
book he was just incredibly playful guy
who's is bringing non petition and and
almost kind of philosopher in a way and
if you went over to his house he had
this kind of toy room and he would sit
they would like love to juggle and he'd
get on his unicycle and he would juggle
any would talk about mathematical
theorems so I got so there is a you know
a rich history in that and and I think
the other thing it's true of math but
true of other things children come into
the world wired to play and the other
thing they come into the world wired to
do when they when they get into those
play states is invent new rules right I
mean this is the beautiful thing about
young kids display is it's not just like
okay we're gonna play this game
according to this rules they say okay
what are the rules going to be this time
and that kind of thinking is a very
high-level form of cognition right let's
design a system let's figure out what
the rules should be let's predict how
those rules are going to affect our
behavior whether it will be fun or not
whether it be engaging up whether it be
challenging enough and let's modify the
rules as we go as we get feedback from
the game and learn whether that worked
well or that made it too boring and that
get made it too easy for one side or the
other that's a very that's almost like
the scientific method in some sense
that's build a hypothesis about this
system and and test it and then modify
it based on the feedback we get from the
system so that's another way in which I
think play in an educational context is
just incredibly important last call for
Steven Johnson comes from Val in Austin
Texas hi Val
Val in Austin Texas one more and we're
going to try ashwin in Sacramento Ashwin
and Phil in Emporia Kansas third time's
a charm right Phil yeah I think so how
are you today
al go ahead religion purpose premise
might make my question my wife and I
worked for many years with FedEx which
most people think of as a transportation
company but in reality when people would
talk to us about it we're really not
were we're a management information
company particularly accurate
information we found that with real-time
information if you know where things are
at all time things will work the right
way and then you deliver the kind of
service that people need and that's a
preface to when you were talking about
different platforms that people rely on
it used to be traditional media but
people have trusted them less and less
and so they've gone to platforms like
Facebook which I have but I don't use I
wonder this is from my wife or myself
most of our information we get from
c-span that's nice too not to tell you
guys but I know if I watch c-span I'm
going to get accurate information right
from the people who are the source of
what I'm trying to find out so I'm
wondering how how all that stuff fits
together well I first off I I agree with
your endorsement of c-span and I think I
mean yeah I hope there is this c-span
both you know book TV but also the
broader kind of purview of c-span that
this idea that these new technologies
were going to give you kind of direct
access to what was going on say what was
going on in Congress for instance so
that would lead to more democratic
participation and what Sabbat is it's
kind of layer of social media has grown
up around all of that and so you you
have almost less direct kind of access
to your leaders you know to speeches
being given or laws being passed or
debated on the House floor and more to
people talking about it on social media
which adds one it makes it more
personable built it into your friend
Network which is lovely
it also creates a possibility for
distortion there and we probably need to
get that balance a little bit a little
bit more balanced here's a book it's
called Wonderland how play made the
modern world as you can see it's very
interesting and colorful and busy
covered even Johnson is the author
thanks for being with us on book TV so
great to be back thank you and book TVs
live coverage of the Miami Book Fair now
continues author Dave berry a local down
here in Florida is speaking next in the
book TV room his newest book best state
ever a Florida man defends his homeland
you